ハンドンされたとき ナヌバンテー
バガワ サッバパナ ブータヒタヌカンピーヴィハラティーティ
エーワンガーミニ タターガト
サッバパナ ブータヒタヌカンピーヴィハラティーティ
世尊は一切の生命に対して憐れみを持っておられるのではないでしょうかと
また ガーミニという人が聞くんです
はい 如来は一切の生命に対して憐れみを持っているとお釈迦様は答えるんです
では なぜある人々に詳細に説法するが
ある人々に省略するのですかと
このガーミニという別なガーミニさんです
お釈迦様に聞くんです
あ 同じ同じガーミニさんです
同じ人です お釈迦様はね
すべての生命に対して憐れみを持ってるでしょ？持ってますよとお釈迦様は答えるのです
では なんである人にはすごく丁寧にきめ細かく説法するんだけど
ある人には省略してなんとか何とか言って終わっちゃいますよ
おかしいんじゃないかっていう話なんです
それでお釈迦様はもう本当に何のこともなく返事するんです
返事の仕方が 仏教では決してこの自分の意見を言いふらすことをしないんです
導くんです 思考 こういうふうに
あ そうね では ガーミニ
君に聞きます 君が好きなように答えてください
田んぼは 3つあります
一つはまあ土地が良くて
すごい平らな土地で 水があって栄養もある立派な田んぼ
抜群 もう一つは まあ中ぐらい
まあ水もそれなりにあるし
まあ土地も別に悪くはない
なんとかすれば作物できます 3
番目の田んぼは最悪 水はないわ
石やらいろんなものがあって
もう平らではないし 例えば山の斜面とかね
最悪のところにあると
では この農業する人が先にどんな田んぼを耕すんでしょうかと
ったら ガーミニさん それだったらもう一番グレードの高い田んぼは先に作るんだよと
理由は確実に穀物は取れます
問題ない 時間があったら中ぐらいの田んぼはやってみる
また時間がなったらどうにもならん時でも種をまいておく
なぜかというと 人間に食べられるようなものをできなくても
あっちこっちで何かできるでしょ
動物でも食べるでしょうと
あるいはもう牛 自分飼ってる牛でもそこら辺に放してあげれば
牛でも犬やらトウモロ
トウモロコシ トウモロコシやらね
食べちゃいますからね
ということで 3番目ですよ
あの悪い畑に手を出す出すのは
とガーミニさんが答えるんです
ブッダじゃないんです
それでガーミニに理性があって
仏教を理解して修行しようと
自分の全財産を捨てて命をかけている私の出家弟子たちがいるんだよと
その人々は覚悟して解脱に達するぞと
命をかけているんだよと
私に頼っているんだよと
私はそういう人々にものすごく丁寧に
ものすごく厳密に ものすごく詳細に説法するんだと
いわゆるというよりも
先に説法するんだと まあ説法は同じですけど
先に説法するんだと なぜかというと
みるみるうちに結果出しますよと
みんなそれからすぐ私はこの私の話を信じてね
実践する最下の人々がいるんだと
その人々も私に頼ってるんだよと 2
番目に財布の人々に説法するんだと
それでたまたまこの邪教の人々もところに行ったら
また同じく説法するんだよと
なぜかというと もしかすると微塵でもこの人々の心は清らかになるでしょうと
ちょっとだけでも良いことをするようになるでしょうと
いう期待ですよ だから順番がある
説法は中身は関係ないんですけど
私はこの詳細と省略っていうのを単語を入れましたけど
お釈迦様の場合はまあそんなことはないんですね
質問ではなんか厳しく質問されたんですけど
質問の場合は丁寧に説法する
ある人には丁寧に説法しないという
お釈迦様はそこを使ってないんです
ただ みんなに法を説くんだよと
それ終わったらまた別な例えを持ってくるんです
ウドか何かっていうのは
この水と水を入れる入れ物
水容器に対して 一つは
しっかりした水を入れる立派な
もう全く微塵も漏れないもの
もう一つは まあちくちくちょこちょこっともう割れ目とかあったりするもので
もう一つはいろいろやっぱり水が漏れると
水を汲む人はどちらに先に水を入れるかというと
立派なものに先に入れるんです
ちょっと容器がちょこっと壊れているんですけど 2
番目に次に入れます また水が残っているならば
漏れるものにも入れておくんです
まあいくらか残すだろうと
そのように誰にでも初めよし
真ん中よし 終わりのよし
説法してますよということで
お釈迦様 その話を終了するんです
だからすごい反論されましたけど
お釈迦様の説法の態度
ちょっとおかしいでしょうと
みんなにいっぺんに 違います
順番がありますよと 優先順がありますよと
結果を見ながら喋りますよということですね
これがそういう はい まあ次に行きましょうか
ブッダは理性に 優れたですね
修行に命をかけてかけた人々に
先に丁寧に詳細に説法する
はい そういうことです
笑い芸人の話 嘘でも本当のことでも
何でも語って踊って舞台で人を笑わすことは尊い行為です
ですから 笑い芸人は正気
天パハサに生まれ変わると師匠たちに教わりました
これは質問なんです この竹林精舎に住んでいる時の話で
ターラプタという笑い芸人
踊り屋さんなんですね
お釈迦様に質問したんです
お釈迦様は 私の先生たちが父親とね
伝統 伝道 そういう代々芸人だ
芸人の家なんです だから我々の師匠たちが何をしてでも舞台の上で人を笑わせなくちゃいけないんだと
これ大変なことやと 大事なことやと
笑い芸人の家族ですから
もう先祖代々同じ職業をしなくちゃいけない
だから父親が師匠で 息子にしっかり教えるんです
これ大変なことだよと
何としてでも人を笑わせなくちゃいけないんだと
尊いことやと 尊いことをすると
笑い芸人に対しては尊い
特別な天国がありますよと
それは正気天という いわゆる笑いを起こす天というパハース
そちらに生まれますと
なんかあのテロ行為やっている人々にも特別な天国を用意しているという話がありますね
だからみんなその特別なとと特許席
何でしたっけ？えっ 特等席を狙って人を殺すんです
だから天国にね まあ五
六人殺したら天国特等席だったらね
まあ何万単位で殺す人々はもっとすぐ神様のそばにいるでしょうね
ヒットラーも神の名前を持って人を殺したし
仏さんも神に言われたんだから
あちらでこちらで戦争したし
今もしているし うーん
私は神にはなりたくないんですよ
ああいう連中近寄ってくるとね
ヒットラーやらムッソリーニやらね
そばにいると それからビンラデンとかね
神はさすが楽しいでしょうね
いい仲間が出て だから人間というのは何言ってるのかと
仏教から見てください
本当に笑い話ですよ 笑い話じゃなくて
どれほど人を不幸に陥れているんですかね
この全く陳腐簡素な話をしたりしていて
それでおかしいことは
人間にこのヘリコプター見えないでしょ
私たちよりも簡単に言っちゃいますけどね
だからもうブッダの教えではね
そこら辺智慧が現れるようにするんです
それでお釈迦様がどう思いますかと
そのような天国は お釈迦様
ちょっとおかしい じゃあテキストから読み上げたいつもりで省略しています
あの この芸人がお釈迦様に言ってお釈迦様
その話本当ですか？と聞くんです
その芸人が本当にお釈迦様にはその天国のことを知っていると知っていたんです
だからお釈迦様に確かめたかったんです
言ったらお釈迦様があのね
ターラプトラ それでもガーミニって言うんですけど
ガーミニ その質問はやめてくれる？というふうにです
やめてくれると頼んでも
この人はいや お釈迦様
自分のそんなこと言ったって
自分の家ではね もう先生たちがこう教えてくれたんだから
私は本当に母とパハサという天国はあるのかと知りたいんだよと
だからお釈迦様  2番目にもガーミニ
その質問 ちょっとよしてくれよと
別なことを聞きましょうと
もう答えようとしないんです 3
回目もまた聞いたんです 3
回目もしたところで お釈迦様
私はね ね あなたはね 私を放っておいてくれませんね 3
回もやめましょう やめましょう
やめましょうと言ったでしょう
私は まだ3回目も質問するんだから
で 答えたんです 厳しい答えですけど
こちら省略しています
この 人々はね 欲があって
怒りがあって 無知があって
芸人たちもまた相手の怒りやら欲やら悲しみやら
あれやこれやと感情を引き起こして
ありもしない芸をやってるでしょ
舞台で美味しい食べ物を見たところで
食べたい食べたい思うのは
もうこれはどうしようもないんですけど
芸人がなんかもうただのあれ
扇子でものすごく美味しくラーメン食わして食わす
食ってるようなことを演じちゃうと
ラーメン食べたくなっちゃうという
これちょっとやりすぎなんですね
だからただのスクリーンで皆様の心の中で怒りも欲も
あれもこれも感情を引き起こすでしょう
舞台の上で全部演技でしょうに
裏でじーっと待っていて
自分の場面ができるまでもうビクビクビクビクしながら待っていて
きっかり出てきてキャーと言ったりとか
まだもっと緊張しちゃってやっとなったとかね
そういう大変ですけどね
そういうことをやったら
悪行為だよ それは 人の心を汚すんだよと
あんた方が 人の心を汚して天国に行ける
そんな私は知りません
そんな天国はと その代わりにパハサという名前の同じ名前の地獄があるんだよと
みんなそちらに落ちるんだ
このパハサパハサっていうのは
このちょっと言葉の遊びもあります
パハサ前はもう笑う天国ですけど
こちらになってくると笑われる
地獄なんです いわゆる侮辱されるという
だからちょっと同じ単語なんです
パハサいう天国じゃなくて
パハサを地獄ならありますよと
そう言われたら この人はいきなり泣き崩れて
もういても立ってもいられない状態になったんです
長い間天国に行くと思っていたのに
やっぱり地獄やと言われると
それまでお釈迦様知ってるんだから嘘言わないでしょ
はっきり言うとパハサという天国はありませんと
知らない そんなのはと
しかし 同じ名前の地獄はあるんだよと
そちらに行きますと泣くと
お釈迦様は心配して 君
私は言ったでしょ？質問をしないでくれと
君の間違いやと ここまで聞いたの
なんかお釈迦様は悲しくなるっていうか
お釈迦様心配したんですね
バスンと答えたんですけど
したくなかったんです
言ったらこの人は いい
お釈迦様 私はお釈迦様がおっしゃったことに全然泣いてないんだよと言うんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは全然気にしていないんだと
私はもう泣いちゃったのは
私たちの師匠たちがあの連中はどれほど私を騙してきたかっていうこと
今まで騙されて騙されて嘘をついちゃってて
お釈迦様に会ってやっと本当のことをわかったんだよと
だからもう二度とあんな汚いことをやりませんと
私は出家しますと すぐ出家するんです
本人が嫌で嫌でやったみたいでしょうにね
だから父親が厳しくて
こんないいことだから天国に行くんだからやれやれと
特に芸人の子供たちというのはすごい厳しいでしょ
生活は遊ぶ暇はないし
ものすごい稽古しなくちゃいけないし
いろんなものを暗記しなくちゃいけないし
この人は嫌でしたからね
でも家の仕事だから それでお釈迦様に本当のことを言われたら
本当もう父親のことを怒って泣いたんです
おじいさんのことを怒って泣いたんです
騙されてきたんだと 父親におじいさんに
師匠たちに 悔しくて なんて苦労したんですかと
私はと 人を笑わせるために
今出家しますということで
本人が出家して 後で瞑想して解脱にも達します
はい 他のテーマに行ってみましょうか
全知全能の神 人は経験する一切の感覚
苦であろう 楽であろう
不幸 福楽であろう すべては神の創造により生じるのだと
とく人は言います 世界に起こるべきことは全部神様の発言である
それなら殺生も中途も邪見も神の創造でしょうと
お釈迦様の答え 全知全能の神がいて
何でもかんでもやってくれるんだったら
人は人を殺しているわ
戦争しているわ 盗んでいるわ
もうもうインサイダー取引やっているわ
いろいろ で 賄賂を取っているわね
自衛隊はまあ ゴルフ場ばっかり遊んでいるわ
漁師さんの船を壊しちゃうわ
まあいろいろやって これ全部神様がやってるんです
例えば子供を誘拐して殺したりするでしょう
時々日本でも起こりますね
出会い 携帯出会いなんとかというサイトでお互い知り合ったりして
それからもう命がない
どこに行ったかわからないとかね
気にしないでください
全知全能の神様がやったことだからね
全部もう人を殺したんだから出て悪いことをしたと思わないでください
いかに簡単にお釈迦様が全知全能の神を馬鹿にしているかって
成り立たないんだよ そんな話はと
すごいシンプルでしょ
世界どれほど苦労してますかね
バチカンは未だに頑張ってますよ
神の存在を証明してやるそうと
ないものはいくら踏ん張ったっても証明できるわけないでしょうに
その代わりにこの迷信に引っかかるんですね
病気治すとか 今の法王よりは前の方はすごい迷信に凝り固めて
祈りで病気治るとかね
いろいろもうもう仙人たちを拝んだりいろいろやったりして
それで神の力があると証明しようと思ったりするんですね
迷信にすがらないと神の存在は証明できないんだからね
迷信も神が人をしているようですけど
まあとにかく うん 全知全能の問題はお釈迦様は最も簡単に解決するんだ
あまり話題に取らないんです
だって全知全能の神があると言ったら
もう殺生してもよろしい
しなくてもよろしい 盗んでもよろしい
盗まなくてもよろしい
構いません あっちこっちで好き勝手に女性を犯しても構いません
その気ならば 神がそうやらせているんだから
もう爆弾仕掛けたくなったらどうぞ
構いません 罪がありません
っていう話ですよ だから宗教にならないんだと
そんなのは いっさりにんまなんこうぱなビクビクウェーサーとパッチャーガタンね
ほーで チャンドーはわやもはイダンカラニーヤンはイダンアカラニーヤンていっさりにんまの創造論を信じると
人は努力する必要なくなるんだよと
これはやるべき これはやってはいけないと
一人一人頑張る必要がなくなるんだよと
今もそうなんですよ 例えば日本の仏教では
神様の代わりに阿弥陀様を設定しているでしょ
何もしなくていいんです
なんまんだって言えば大丈夫
終わり もう永久的に天国
あるいは南無妙法蓮華経と言えばもう天国というか
どこか行くんですね だから行くところはブッダの言葉から言えますよ
そんなのはありえない
嘘でしょうに だってそれだけで心清らかになるはずがないでしょ
死んでからお坊さんが遺体の前でお経あげると成仏になると言ったら
これっておかしいに決まってるでしょうに
善も悪も心の心に起こるものでしょ
もう心がないんです だから邪見でしょ
間違ってる意見だから
邪見持っちゃうとどこに行くかとお釈迦様に聞いてください
私は言いません だからまあ
そういうことで まあまあ
ちょっと例に出しただけで
皆様この浄土系の話はなじみがありますね
なんかすごいやりやすいでしょ
念仏となればいいんです
しつけはないんです こういう言葉あるみたいでしょ
千人さえも救われますからと
なんか親鸞そう言ったみたいですね
いかに善行為をすることが馬鹿にしているのかと
頑張ることは 普通は悪人さえも救われますからと言うんですけど
それはわざと 千人さえも救われますよ
念仏唱えればと だから
あの 厳しい言葉なんですけど
同時に極限に邪見ということでもあります
そういうことに我々は微塵もめげません
だから 私たちには生きている
この世の中でどうすれば怒りを抑えるか
どうすれば嫉妬を抑えられるか
どうすれば相手を憎まないで済むか
どうすれば我々は仲良くすればいい
それがでしょうね 必要なのは
いじめられてもそれに耐えられる精神
どうやって作ればよろしいかと
経済状況悪化してもとにかく持ちこたえる
力がどうでしょうかとかね
家族の中でも子供は病気になったりするわ
不良に走ったりするわ
そういう時でも我々はなんとかしてうまく解決する
精神的な力 落ち着き 知恵
能力 それが育てる方法でしょう
必要なのは それはいらんだそうです
何も だからまあ お釈迦様がこの相相論を否定したところで
一切の相相論まがいなものも否定されます
はい それから哲学者に会った時
あるバラモン人が来てこう言うんですよ
私は自由意志はあると思わない
また 他人の意思で生きているとも思わない
生命に対する自作他作論の否定ですよと釈尊に告げるんです
これ インド哲学では大変な難しいポイントなんです
いわゆる自由意志がないんだと
これ 結構調べていってますよ
例えばお腹が空くでしょ
勝手にお腹が空くでしょ
なるほどと思わない？じゃあ皆様にできますか？自分好き勝手にお腹が空いたり空かなかったり
私は自由だと思って 今お腹が空かないでくれとできる
でお腹が空いたら食べる
食べなくちゃあかんでしょ
自由があると思う じゃあ食べる時は好き勝手に食べると思う
こちらに木の葉っぱ取って食べようとか
道路にある草を取って
まあまあ軽々くありますから
この雑草でしょ じゃあ食べますとか
自由がある？ないんです
雑草は食べません キャベツは食べられますけど
そういうことを見てみると
病気になりたくないんですけど
勝手に病気になるでしょうに
自由意志がないんだと
若い男たちはね 恋はするんだけど
それ若い女猫に恋するんであって
カラスには恋しませんし
猫にも恋しませんね 自由がないんですよ
そこらにある柱見て いやーあんたのこと大好きやとか言えばいいのに
言わないんです それで女性もいくらたくさんいるんですけど
また一人を狙うんですね
それで友達があのね その女の人じゃなくて
この女の人がいいんだよと
でももうそれしません
自分が狙ったものに行くんです
だからそういうことを考えちゃうと
自由意志がないように見えますね
それで逆にこのバラモンが
では他人 誰か神様みたいな
全部管理していると これも認めません
このバラモン人は だから人の運命は自作でも他作でもないという
自分の深い哲学なんです
一生研究したでしょうね
それでお釈迦様は一言葉でチャラにするんです
あんたは自分で歩きながら
座りながら何を言ってるんですかと
それで話終わり じゃあ自分で座るでしょ
誰か座らせたじゃないでしょ
何言ってるの あんたはと
それあの人の一生の哲学は一言葉で消えてしまうという
そこでお釈迦様はなおさら冗談を言うんです
私はね このような哲学思考っていうのは聞いたこともないんだよと
なおさら笑っちゃいます
お釈迦様というのはものすごい知識人でもあったし
インドの思想 哲学 宗教というのは全部知り尽くしていたんです
バラモン人にはもう比較できんほど
そういう人が言う お釈迦様が言うならば
あのね あなたの言うような考え方はね
聞いたこともないんだと
なおさらからかっちゃうんです
聞いたこともないと言ってからね
自分で歩きながら 自分で座りながらね
よく言うんだよと はい
えーと たくさんありますけど
まあちょっとさっさといきます
サイケも負けません お釈迦様の時代ではサイケもまあ口はうるさいんです
というか 品格のある有意義な役に立つヒューマンユーモアなんです
だから皆様 今までの一つに笑わなかったでしょう
これっていうのは ちょっと品格が高すぎなんです
で 下ネタはないんです
すごい哲学に対して一言葉で笑ってみせるんです
と同時に哲学も潰れていくんです
この世の中はもう九十五パーセント以上
人々九十パーセントぐらいね
神様は信仰しているでしょ
科学者もいるし 哲学者もいるし
もう大なる人いっぱい
お釈迦様から見れば一言葉で捨てられてます
だからまあ そこはもうちょっと
あの本当は冗談笑いで言ってるんです
じゃあサイケの話に戻りましょう
ナクラ夫婦は仲良しで
とっても仲良し夫婦なんです
夫が病で倒れました 妻はこのように励みます
あんたは未練を残したままで死んではならない
そのような死に方は不幸に陥るとブッダは忠告しています
読めますか？冗談は 奥さんが普通ならなんとか早く治してちょうだいと
この奥さん何？早く死んでください
それ言ってます 早く死んでよと
しかし これおしどり夫婦で
仏教では有名なんです
このナクラ夫婦はあんまりにも二人が仲が良くて
どれほど仲がいいかというと
このすごく年取ったところで
この夫が言うんです この人は十六歳で結婚したんだよと
私は今まで 私に気に入らない
気に入らないことっていうのは一つもやったことがないんだと
表でも隠れてでも いない時でも
私に気に入らちょこっとした一言葉をかけたことはないんだと
奥さんも同じことを言ったんです
私はいきなり家からね
この男のところに連れて行かれたんですけど
この日からこの人はね
私に気に障ることっていうのは一つもやったことがない
それぐらい夫婦はいいんですよ
なのに病気になっても倒れたところで言うこと
早く死んでよと 自分 しかし
未練があって死んではならんと死に方を教えてあげるんです
自分が死んだら私は困ると思うでしょ
木よりなどの仕事は上手です
私は機織り 私は糸もあれ作れますよと
機織りもできますよと
またいろんな作業できますよと
だから心配しないでください
ということは なんか侮辱みたいなもんでしょうね
あの この女の人 私が死んじゃったら
もうどうやって食べてる
困って気にしないでくださいと
仕事できますと 家を守って子供を養うことは私にできますよと言うんです
あなたは死んだら私が再婚するだろうと困っている
心配いりませんと あなたも私も 16 年間盆行を守っているでしょう
ですから 再婚の気持ちは微塵もありませんと
この二人も仏教徒になって瞑想したりしていたんだから
もう 16 年目ですよ 何のお互いすっくなきゃですけど
それ以上の関係はないんです
16 年間もあなたと一緒にいながら
私は何の欲も出してないんだから
再婚するとかね ありえないんだからね
うん あなたがいなかったら
ブッダにサンガに会うことはやめるだろうと心配するでしょうと
これもあります だから夫婦で行くんだからね
ブッダに会うために サンガに会うために
説法を聞くために夫婦で行くんです
だから旦那が亡くなっちゃうと
奥さんが一人で行けないでしょう
夫はそれ心配するかも
心配いりません あんたが亡くなったらね
かえってたくさん時間があります
今よりも何回でもブッダにサンガに会うことができますと
この世に早く死んでも死んでも結構ですというと言われたら
夫の病気はたちまち治るんです
またいくつかありますけど
言ったことはね それで終わらなかったんです
もうたくさんなります
ね で この理屈はなかなかわからないと思いますよ
最後にね あの あんたね
私がもう仏教をあまり理解していないとかね
自分がいないとお互い話し合う人も相手もいないしね
ブッダの教えはああだこうだとかね
あんた心配するでしょうと
しかし 私が仏教はほとんど理解して
もう自分のものにしているんだよと
いわゆる悟りに達しているんだという話なんです
もし心配ならね ブッダに聞いてみたらどうですかと
私の理解能力について
必ずお釈迦様は私に反抗してくれますよと
この娘さんは仏教を経験しているんだよというふうに
どんどん項目がたくさんあります
そこで なんでこの夫の病気が治りましたんですかね
そこで夫婦ではなくて
ものすごいレベルの高い世界で
これって各生命が生きているんであって
何にでも執着あるとまずい
執着はありえない 成り立たない
だからわざとあの死にかけている瞬間で
奥さんが別に奥さんから見れば病気治ったってもまあいいんじゃない？死んじゃったらまあいいんじゃない？という調子なんです
偉大なる人々ですよ あんたの旦那死んだらまあいいんじゃない？病気になったら別にいいと思いますよと
どちらでもいいんです
どちらでもいいんだよということを言うと
あ なるほど これこそ仏教だとわかったところで
いきなり心が究極に清らかになるんですよ
心が究極に清らかになると
病気がひと欠けらもなく治るんです
それでこの旦那さんがもうまだまだ体が弱いんで
倒れていたんだからね
据えを持ってこそこそとお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
行って奥さんのことを言うんですね
うちのものはね 私はもう倒れて本当に死にかけていたんだよと
その時こんなことを言いましたからと
お釈迦さん何をおっしゃったんですかね
いい奥さんでよかったねと
そう その通りですと 旦那さんが返事するんです
本当にその通りですと
いい人でよかったと そういう夫婦関係っていうのは
仏教では理想的な夫婦関係として取っているケースなんです
ちょっと無理でしょう
皆様には だから仏教の在家の方々はもう並大抵じゃないんです
これって冗談というか
何言うんですかね でも我々平気で言うんですよ
私は平気で言うんです
例えば人が本当に病気でやっても
調子がすごく悪いんだったら
もう準備できたの？と聞くんです
何のことなく聞くんです
これ 患者さんに接する時
何でもないんです 準備できて
あんた死ぬ準備できたの？って話ですよ
それで患者さんもニコッと笑っちゃうんです
結構治りますよ しかし
正直に言わないと治らないんです
こちらはあなた 本当にもう準備できているんですかねと
すごい真剣に言うと 本人もそうだね
やっぱり いろいろ自分がやった良いことを思い出したりして
じゃあ今更今でもいいんだから
なんとかお布施でもしなくちゃとか
で 息子たちにみんな呼んで
もう何かお布施でも何かやってくださいとかね
私はいろいろおじいさんたち
おばあさんたちに呼ばれて行くときありますけど
もう最後に臨終の時になったら
一応国にいる場合は呼ばれますよ
で 子供たちやら来て おばあさんがお母さんがもう倒れてますけどとかね
もう先生の名前を呼んでいるんだよと
そしたら行きますと 言ったら
私を呼んで何するのかというと
もう息子たちの娘たちのことはもう嫌で
側にいるのは だって自分の母親でしょ
この薬飲んでください
で これ塗ってくださいとかね
病院に行きましょうとか
お医者さん家に呼びましょうか
うるさくてうるさくて
私が行ったらもうニコッと笑ってお坊さん
私はね もう準備できてるんだから
もう長い間ね いろんなこれこれこれこれやってね
もう十分やと だから心配しないでくださいと
私もまあそう じゃあまあということで
じゃあ ok でもあげましょうかとかね
ちょこっと下のお経をあげたりとか
あるいはちょこちょこっと世間話をして帰るんです
何のこと 本当に穏やかに亡くなるんです
でもだいたい私が行ったら亡くならないケースっていうのはほとんどでしたから
これ私も心配ですけど
体がボロボロで 自分がいて喋っちゃうと
またたちまちまた元気になるんだからね
まあそれがいいかどうかわからないし
準備できる人っていうのは美しいんですよ
死ぬ時は あれは子供たちにとってはやっぱり家族でしょうし
親でしょうし いくらなんでも感情が表に出るんです
だからもう言いたい放題のことを言うために
お寺のお坊さん呼んでもらっちゃうんですね
言いたい言いたいことを言って亡くなると
で 息子たちはね あまり仏教に興味ないとこ
お寺のことに参加しないとかね
あれこれ言われたっても
心配あったっても だから亡くなる人がもう徹底的にそうやって信頼関係があって
最後にも言いたいことはお坊さんに言って亡くなったんだから
亡くなった途端 もうもう子供たちも次
また伝統を守って持っていくんです
やっぱりお寺のことやらなくちゃ
仏教のことやらなくちゃって
そうやって伝統は今まで伝わってきたんです
だから 病気で倒れた人にいきなり早く死んでよっていうのはね
それは仏教の人以外はできるものじゃないんです
そちらに早く迷惑だから早く死んでって意味じゃないんですよ
レベル高い考え方なんです
それを理解したら すぐ病気は治ります
またありますかね よくできたお母さんでしょうと釈尊も夫に言う
はい もう一つエピソード
神々に頼る人 神々の対策点が用事があって出かけようとする
乗り物に乗る前に四方八方に礼をする
この神々の王様 運転手のマータリー
神が聞く 王たちも人間も四天の神々もあなたを拝む
あなたは今どれほどの威力のある神に礼をしているのでしょうかと
だから 八百万の神々の中で王様がいるんですよ
この王様が用事があって出かけ出かける前に
自分の身を守るためにも何か礼をしているんです
あちらに礼をして こちらに礼をして
こちらに礼をして それで車に乗るんです
日本車じゃないんです
車はアメリカ製でもないんです
天国どこか工場で作ったものです
で かなり派手な車みたいんです
日本語できないんだから放っておいたんです
それでこの神々の王様は誰？どんな神を礼をするんですかね
それ答えなんです ゲーガッタプンヤカラシーラワンタウパーサカダンメナダランポーセンティテーナマッサーミマーテリー
サイケで善行為をする
道徳を守る また合法で家族を養う人々
私はその人々に合掌しているんだと
意味わかりますかね 皆様方
あちこちでお祈り 神社やらあれやこれやとはね
惨めでおねだりしているんですけど
神々の一番トップの王様が
サイケの合法的で道徳を守っている人に守ってほしいと思っているんです
仏教は逆を言ってるんです
我々は立派な人間になって
神々を守ってあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
惨めでしょうね あれちょうだい
これちょうだいとか 私は言いませんよ
あれこれちょうだいとか
行ったこともないんです
逆に助けてあげるということをします
それは仏教的なんです
仏教は神に祈るんじゃない
神を助けてあげる どうやって我々は道徳を守ると
善行をすると良いことをすると
我々の心からとても清らかな波動が放つんです
神々はそこは栄養にするんです
だから怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやらね
隣の家の子供よりは自分の子供の方が合格してほしいとかね
そんな気持ちで祈願したりお祈りしたりしたっても
この汚い波動でしょうに
まあ餓鬼はやってくるかもしれませんだけど
神は寄ってこないんです
ついでにもう一つエピソードを言います
神々の世界だから これも本物を知りたければ仏典読まないと
この帝釈天という神の神の王座がありますよ
玉座 これは誰も近寄らないし
触ろうともしない あまりも威力のある座る場所なんです
そちらに突然ある霊が現れたんですよ
霊的な存在  仏教では霊といっておかしいんですけど
マヌッサとアマヌッサという言葉
マヌッサは人間 アマヌッサは人間でない存在という言葉を使ってます
現れたんです この あの玉座の真ん上
それでこの人はもう天界に現れたんですけども
ものすごい気持ち悪いみたい
全くもう微塵も美しさがなくて
見る限り気持ち悪くなる
それから体もあちこちねじ曲がっていて
いわゆる究極的に醜い姿でしたと
それでこの帝釈天の神々が見たら
もう見ていられない もう気持ち悪くなる
いきなりなんだこれはと
この我々触ろうともしないところで
なんで座っているんでしょうかと
やりたい放題 侮辱 誹謗中傷しているんです
あの汚い醜い霊を これで神々が一斉に侮辱すればするほど
この醜い霊がどんどんどんどん体が成長していくんです
成長して成長して どんな力
威力発揮するんです どんどん輝くんです
醜くたっても この輝きは負けますからね
威力で 神々が追っ払おうと思ったんですけど
全くもできない お手上げ
それで帝釈天に行ったんです
大変なことになっていますよと
汚い天国に行ってはならない生命が玉座に座っているんで
追い出そうとすればするほど力強くなるんだろうと
帝釈天はまあ真面目な仏教徒なんです
ああ そう わかりました
行って あの玉座のところに行って
何のことなく土下座をして礼をするんです
肢体もつけて あの 私はこの
この天国の王である帝釈天でございます
お礼いたしますと と一回お礼しただけで
じーっと静んじゃうんです
それでもう一回また立ち上がって
二回目もお礼したんです
名前挙げて いわゆる究極的な礼
ちょっと頭下げるぐらいじゃないんです
で 三回目やった後 三回目やるとあっと言っかたもなくちらっと消えたんです
あの霊が これどういうことかというと
このあの帝釈天に現れた霊が
この怒りを栄養にするんですよ
怒りの波動が入るとどんどん成長するんです
だからああいうところを選んだんです
絶対入ってはならないところ
なんとかして入ったでしょうね
そちらに入ったら当然侮辱される
非難される これが欲しかったんです
だからもう非難されればされるほどもう成長したんです
これが仏教を知っている帝釈天が
こんなことで追い出せませんよと
いくら頑張っても 言って逆をしてみたんですね
礼をして それで消えちゃったんです
そういうことで この神々はやっぱりレベル高い品のある神々が
やっぱり人間の清らかな心を期待しているんです
だから不正で生活したりとかね
違法な行為やったりとかね
神に守ってもらうと思ったらね
ちょっと難しいかも 嫉妬で
憎しみで いろいろ祈願したり
お札を買ったりしたっても
ちょっと無理が で 覚えておきましょう
では 神よりも威力がある人は誰でしょうか？と
だからこの項目で 仏教では人間がやっている
毎日やっている この神々に礼をすることに対して
仏教は本当はニコッと笑っているんです
もっと立派なことはないんじゃないのかと
あまり神がいるかいなかったか
そんなどうでもいい話には口を挟みません
笑って問題解決する で
乞食 乞食 乞食の老人を助けるという
これ ちょっと質の違うエピソードなんですね
あるブラマン人がね 子供は４人がいて
大事に育てたんですよ
もう可愛くて可愛くて
しっかり育てたんです
で 大人になったら まあ財産全部分けてあげたんです
結構財産があったんです
それで子供たちはもうお父様
お父様 お父様 父親 父親と言いながらね
もう面倒見たんだから
もうまあバラモン文化ではね
まあ一応子供が大人になったら全財産分けてあげなくちゃいけないし
自分が引退しなくちゃいけないんです
だからまあ財産分けましょうと言っちゃうと
父親が４人にも均等に分けてあげたんです
まあ決まりだから それから自分には何もなし
で 親の面倒を見るのはもう子供の義務でもあります
しかし この子供４人が親を追い出しちゃったんです
追い出したって もう食べるものはない
それであれほど金持ちでしたけど
乞食をやる羽目になったんです
耐えられますかね 金持ちの人がもう自分の財産があるにも関わらず
息子がすごい贅沢しているのに
自分が乞食をしなくちゃいけない
一番長男のところに行ったら
もうあんたなんで家に居座りしているんでしょう
私に特別に何かあげたのかと
みんなに同じでしょうと
と ２番目に行かせると言って ２
番目も同じことを言う ３
番目も同じことを言う
だから まあ息子たちにそんなこと言われて欲しくないということで
乞食になった それでお釈迦様にそのことを言ったら
お釈迦様が歌を作ってあげたんです
お釈迦様 そんなにみんな普通思っているほど偉い怖い人じゃないんです
お釈迦様はこういう本当に困っているんだと
ああそう じゃあ歌作ってあげよう
歌作ってあげたんです
だって乞食をやる場合は何か言わなくちゃあかんでしょ
これ インドはそういう歌とかいろいろありますよ
なんとかドラムやったりして
何か楽器を弾いたりして
ちょこっと歌ってお金ちょうだいと言うんです
こじきはあれ ストリートパフォーマンスじゃないんです
お釈迦様はわかりました
じゃあ歌を作ってあげますと
で 歌を作ったんですよ
お釈迦様が作った歌だからもうグッド
で 内容は出てるんでしょうかね
あの末は凶暴な犬も牛も追い払ってくれます
くれる 自分が愛情を注ぎながら育てた人間に隠れた鬼である息子たちよりはありがたいと
この末は そういう意味が最後にありまして
私から物をもらう時は
父親 父親 父親と言い張ったりしたんですけど
あれは息子ではなかったと
本当は人間の顔をした人間に変身した
実は鬼でしたと 今私を野良犬のように追っ払うんだよと
しかし 私にこの末はあの息子より大事だよと
なぜかというと 犬が来ても追っ払うことはできるし
牛が来ても追っ払うことはできますよという
で これを公のみんな集まるところで歌ってみてくださいと
歌ったんです 息子たちの性格は皆にバレたんです
社会の批判を浴びながら生活できないので
父親の面倒を見ることになるんです
もう社会には顔を出せませんよ
堂々と一人前で社会に返す
できんでしょう 自分の父親こじきやってるんだから
それでまた半年から半年だけ面倒見て追い出すことできると思いますか？大丈夫
追い出したらまたあの歌を歌います
だからお釈迦様はすごいことをなさるんですよ
ブッダという武器を持ったので
これから安心でしたと
はい これで終了します
時間は長く向かったからね
内心は明るく またエピソードあるならば
もうたくさんあります
もう言います 生きるのは大変です
物事はうまくいくよりは失敗するケースが多いんです
客観的に見ると 何でも面白くおかしく見ることはできるんです
ずっと私はヴィパッサナー瞑想を教えたりしているのは
この客観的に見なさいよと
面白いんだよと おかしいんだよと
何を見ても だから笑えるんです
人のプライド 尊厳を大事にするならば
何が起こっても笑って生活することはできるんです
だから笑ってもいいんですよ
人をからかってもいいんだけど
一つだけ気をつけてほしい
人のプライドだけ傷つかないでください
人間として立派な平等であることだけを忘れないでください
私は動物に対しても 自分と同じ平等やって態度でアプローチするので
言いたい放題言いますよ
動物たちにも だから時々自分の長老にこいつは頭がいかれてるなと何回も言われたんですけど
でも私は自分言うことを理解してくれるとよく知ってるんだからね
何のことないんです だからこの私たちは人のことを笑ってもいいんです
しかし その人の尊厳 人格としての
それだけ傷つかないように気をつければ
もう結構笑って生活できます
で  それで終わりと思います
はい そういうことで 長い時間長くなりましたけど
仏教の世界っていうのはとても笑いに溢れている
しかし 品格のある 役に立つ
頭がすごく鋭く働く 笑いに溢れている世界なんです
で 私に個人的ないろいろ質問
今までした質問で皆さんは観察していると
私はそのブッダの智慧で結構答えていることが発見できると思います
この最近 自分が結婚したい人がいて
親がもう会ってもくれないという話だったら
あんたね お父さんにね
私にぴったし合う人を探してくださいと頼んでみてくださいと言ったんですね
だから やってみればうまくいきますよ
どちらもわからないんですけど
そういうのはお釈迦様もだいたいそういう風に何か面白いことを言ってあげるんです
で 結構面白い世界なんです
はい どうもありがとうございます
はい